This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真实。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓，我一定要成为他最后一个目标。他绝不能逍遥法外。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到他应得的惩罚。我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。听听闺蜜们怎么说。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。对于1979年来说，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人来说。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要表现出来。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让一名女子怀上双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吧？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两名男子也经历了同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions. of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today we are talking about an ancient philosophy, which I think normally conjures up an image of bottling up your emotions, pretending not to care, pushing through the hard times.
后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，我是杰玛·斯佩克，欢迎回到《二十岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论二十岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们要继续剖析二十岁的心理。今天我们要谈论一种古老的哲学，我认为它通常会让人联想到压抑情绪、假装不在乎、硬撑着度过难关的形象。
with no signs of suffering, no signs of emotion, you know, rugged men, a stiff upper lip. That is, of course, the philosophy of stoicism, as many of us think we know it. As you will come to discover in this episode, stoicism has a bit of a PR problem. It is not all about suppressing negative emotions and suffering in silence. it is actually one of the most empowering mindsets that we can develop in our 20s because of how it really helps us just ride the waves of chaos and of change that this decade is going to bring us. I personally feel like so much of my 20s has involved me trying to control everything and make everything perfect and make everything just as I imagined it.
没有痛苦的迹象，没有情绪的流露，你知道，坚毅的男人，守口如瓶。这当然就是我们许多人所认为的斯多葛主义。正如你将在本集中发现的那样，斯多葛主义在公关方面有点问题。它并不全是关于压抑负面情绪和默默忍受。它实际上是我们二十岁时可以培养的最具赋能的心态之一，因为它确实帮助我们驾驭这个十年将带给我们的混乱和变化的浪潮。我个人觉得我二十岁的大部分时间都在试图控制一切，让一切变得完美，让一切都如我所愿。
if you can relate, I feel like this is the episode for you, because stoicism basically says, stop forcing it. Stop trying to change the things you cannot change. This 3,000-year-old philosophy is all about, instead, mastering what we can control. We can control our response to the world. We can control our actions, our attitude, our self-control. So today, let's talk about it. Let's break down what we can control, what we can't, the four cardinal virtues of stoicism, that being wisdom, justice, courage, temperance, and how exactly you and I can apply them in our 20s and beyond for a more peaceful, centered life. I also want to talk about, of course, the psychology studies, the neuroscience studies looking at what stoicism does to our brains. You know, it is one of the
如果你有同感，我觉得这一集很适合你，因为斯多葛主义基本上说的是，别再强求了。别再试图改变你无法改变的事情。这种有3000年历史的哲学，其核心在于掌握我们能控制的东西。我们可以控制我们对世界的反应。我们可以控制我们的行动、态度和自制力。所以今天，让我们来谈谈它。让我们剖析一下什么是我们可以控制的，什么是不能控制的，斯多葛主义的四大美德，即智慧、正义、勇气、节制，以及你和我究竟该如何在二十岁及以后应用它们，以获得更平静、更专注的生活。当然，我还想谈谈心理学研究、神经科学研究，看看斯多葛主义对我们的大脑有什么影响。你知道，它是
most mentally rewarding and powerful ways of thinking out there, it can literally change what your brain looks like. And I think a lot of modern interpretations don't necessarily cover that and don't necessarily let us see that. So I'm so excited for this episode. Without further ado, let's get into the psychology of stoicism. Let's begin with something actually separate to the psychology we normally focus on. Let's talk about the history of stoicism. So the philosophy of stoicism, it first appeared during what is called the Hellenistic period. That's around like 400, 300 BC. And it was created by this man called Xeno of Citium. Zeno, Zeno, Zeno, Zeno, Zeno, not too sure, but let's go with Xeno. Zeno of Sitium. And he was a very wealthy, rich man.
最令人精神上获得回报和强大的思维方式之一，它甚至可以从字面上改变你大脑的样子。我认为许多现代解读并不一定涵盖这一点，也不一定让我们看到这一点。所以我对这一集感到非常兴奋。废话不多说，让我们进入斯多葛主义的心理学。让我们从一个实际上与我们通常关注的心理学分开的话题开始。让我们谈谈斯多葛主义的历史。斯多葛主义哲学最早出现在所谓的希腊化时期。大约在公元前400到300年左右。它是由一个叫基提翁的芝诺的人创立的。芝诺，芝诺，芝诺，芝诺，芝诺，不太确定，但我们就叫他芝诺吧。基提翁的芝诺。他是一个非常富有的人。
and he miraculously survived this shipwreck. And then after the shipwreck, he came back to Athens. Whilst he was there, he was feeling very enlightened by this near-death experience, also a little bit bored. So he went into a bookshop and he found the writings of a very famous philosopher called Socrates, who you may probably have heard of. And he was so, like, enthralled by this writing, so impressed that he basically became friends with all these philosophers, he wanted to be around them all the time, he decided he was going to
他奇迹般地在一次海难中幸存下来。海难之后，他回到了雅典。当他在那里时，他感到这种濒死体验让他非常开悟，但也感到有点无聊。于是他走进一家书店，发现了非常著名的哲学家苏格拉底的著作，你可能听说过他。他被这些文字深深吸引，印象深刻，以至于他基本上与所有这些哲学家成为了朋友，他想一直和他们在一起，他决定他要
become a philosopher, he changed, he had a little career change, very 20-something of him, and he started thinking a lot about life and about death and about all these other things, and through that he constructed stoicism, which developed a very large following. Fun fact, the name Stoicism actually comes from Stoiaopoli, which is painted porch, I think, in Greek, and him and his disciples used to sit on this porch and talk about life, and that's where the name Stoicism came from. Very, very whimsical. So at the heart of this philosophy is the belief that everything around us operates according to a web of cause and effect. And that results in the rational structure of the universe that the Stoics called Logos. Within this universal structure
成为一名哲学家，他改变了，他有了一个小小的职业转变，非常符合二十多岁人的特点，他开始深入思考生活、死亡以及所有其他事情，通过这些，他构建了斯多葛主义，并发展了一大批追随者。有趣的事实是，斯多葛主义（Stoicism）这个名字实际上来自Stoiaopoli，我想在希腊语中是“彩绘门廊”的意思，他和他的弟子们过去常坐在那个门廊上谈论生活，这就是斯多葛主义名字的由来。非常非常奇特。所以这种哲学的核心是相信我们周围的一切都是按照因果关系网运作的。这导致了斯多葛学派所称的“逻各斯”（Logos），即宇宙的理性结构。在这个普遍结构之内
is the core Stoic belief that the world just has to be dealt with as it is. Instead of trying to drastically change it, there is a real deep sense of acceptance. One particularly influential Stoic, his name was Epic Titus. He has a very famous quote about this where he basically says, we don't suffer from what is actually happening in our lives. We suffer because of how we interpret what is happening in our lives. basically it is our judgment of things that are happening that makes us suffer and we can change that judgment we can change that interpretation so that we suffer less in this way stoicism basically says
是斯多葛派的核心信念，即世界必须按其本来面目去应对。与其试图剧烈地改变它，不如有一种深刻的接受感。一位特别有影响力的斯多葛派哲学家，他的名字叫爱比克泰德。他有一句关于此的名言，他基本上说，我们不是因为生活中实际发生的事情而受苦。我们受苦是因为我们如何解读生活中发生的事情。基本上，是我们对正在发生的事情的判断让我们受苦，我们可以改变那种判断，我们可以改变那种解读，这样我们受苦就会减少。通过这种方式，斯多葛主义基本上说
we can only control our own behavior and our own sense of self our own way of acting and if you're going to choose a way of acting you should aim to be kind you should aim to be tolerant you should aim to be a self-controlled individual, those are the most prized attributes of all, and through that you gain a lot of peace and clarity. To be that kind of person, you have to balance these four core attributes that we spoke about before. So wisdom, courage, justice, and temperance. Wisdom, and this is very core of stoicism, these are like the four things that you really should be. Wisdom is the ability to see what is good, bad, neutral, and to be able to question things as well and explore how things are in the world. Courage is the ability to face hard things and to be okay
我们只能控制我们自己的行为和我们自己的自我意识，我们自己的行事方式，如果你要选择一种行事方式，你应该力求善良，你应该力求宽容，你应该力求成为一个自律的人，这些是最珍贵的品质，通过这些，你获得了内心的平静和清晰。要成为那样的人，你必须平衡我们之前谈到的这四个核心属性。即智慧、勇气、正义和节制。智慧，这是斯多葛主义的核心，这就像你真正应该具备的四件事。智慧是分辨什么是好、坏、中性的能力，也是质疑事物并探索世界现状的能力。勇气是面对困难并能够接受的能力
with discomfort. It's the ability to be okay that life is sometimes suffering. Justice is the ability to be kind, to be fair, to be a power for good. And temperance basically means self-control, not asking or wanting for too much of anything in the world, whether that's success, validation, money, praise, substances, that sort of thing. That should be your focus. If you focus on being a good person and mastering those four things, you can change how you interpret the world so that the world feels more positive towards you. This may make us believe that stoicism is all about personal peace and nothing else. And it's actually not as self-centered as you think and it's not as passive about the lives of others as you may think.
面对不适。这是能够接受生活有时就是痛苦的能力。正义是善良、公平、成为一股向善力量的能力。而节制基本上意味着自制，不要求或渴望世界上太多的任何东西，无论是成功、认可、金钱、赞美、物质等等。那应该是你的重点。如果你专注于做一个好人并掌握那四件事，你就可以改变你解读世界的方式，让世界对你感觉更积极。这可能会让我们认为斯多葛主义完全是关于个人平静，别无其他。实际上它并不像你想象的那么以自我为中心，也不像你想象的对他人生活那么被动。
It basically just says, thinking about how terrible the world is isn't in a change the world unless you work on being a good person. being a good stoic, being a good person, benefits others because it's only those of us who have cultivated this great internal life and this internal life of virtue who can bring about positive change and who can see the world clearly and act on what really does need fixing. And that is like the biggest goal. To give you another quote from another very famous, I guess stoic, Marcus Aurelius, basically he said, you know, stop wasting time arguing about whether the world is good, just prove that the world is good. And I genuinely think that is one of the most powerful
它基本上只是说，思考世界有多糟糕并不能改变世界，除非你致力于做一个好人。做一个好的斯多葛派，做一个好人，会造福他人，因为只有那些培养了这种伟大的内在生活和这种美德的内在生活的人，才能带来积极的改变，才能清晰地看待世界，并对真正需要修复的事情采取行动。这就是最大的目标。再引用另一位非常著名的，我想说是斯多葛派哲学家，马可·奥勒留的话，他基本上说，你知道，别再浪费时间争论世界是否美好，只需证明世界是美好的。我真心认为这是最强大的
philosophies that we can have in this day and age. Especially like for me, I feel like that resonates so much. I find so much peace and meaning and power, I guess. Is that the right word? Yeah, power. Just knowing that I cannot change how others behave. I cannot make them do or be the kind of people that I want to be, I just have to be that person as an example. So although Stoicism has a very ancient origin, it is one of those philosophies that has survived so many versions of the world, so many versions of humanity. So where are we at with it today? Not a surprise.
哲学之一，我们可以在这个时代拥有。特别是对我来说，我觉得这引起了极大的共鸣。我找到了如此多的平静、意义和力量，我想是这样吗？是的，力量。仅仅知道我无法改变他人的行为。我无法强迫他们做我想让他们做的人，或者成为我想让他们成为的人，我只需要以身作则成为那样的人。所以虽然斯多葛主义有着非常古老的起源，但它是那种在这么多版本的世界、这么多版本的人性中幸存下来的哲学之一。那么我们今天处于什么位置呢？并不奇怪。
Stoicism is having a bit of a moment. I've been seeing a lot of videos about it. I've been seeing a lot of content about it. I think there are a few reasons. Firstly, I think the major spike we saw in like the uptick of stoicism as a guiding psychology and philosophy happened during the COVID-19 pandemic. Where else? There was so little that we could control and there was so much isolation. And so people naturally are turning to a solution. And when they can't control anything, obviously a philosophy that says that's okay is going to be pretty alluring.
斯多葛主义现在正处于一个热门时期。我看到了很多关于它的视频。我看到了很多关于它的内容。我认为有几个原因。首先，我认为我们看到的斯多葛主义作为一种指导心理学和哲学的兴起，主要发生在COVID-19大流行期间。还能在哪里呢？我们能控制的东西太少了，而且有太多的孤立。所以人们自然而然地转向一种解决方案。当他们无法控制任何事情时，一种说“没关系”的哲学显然会非常有吸引力。
here is an interesting fact. During the lockdowns, during the pandemic, Penguin, the one of the world's biggest publishers, basically said that their books about stoicism were one of the most, the best-selling books out there. Sales of some of their texts rose by 42%, 356% in some cases, like hundreds of percentages of increases from previous years. People were really getting on the Stoicism train. And when you think about the turbulent, often terrifying world we live in, that is full of powerful leaders doing terrible things and a climate catastrophe and images of genocide and war and suffering, I think we can really see why most people aren't going any other way. And we begin to understand just where this search for meaning is really
这里有一个有趣的事实。在封锁期间，在大流行期间，企鹅图书，世界上最大的出版商之一，基本上说他们的斯多葛主义书籍是市场上最畅销的书籍之一。他们的一些文本的销量增长了42%，在某些情况下增长了356%，比往年增长了百分之几百。人们真的开始追随斯多葛主义了。当你想到我们生活在这个动荡不安、往往令人恐惧的世界中，充满了做着可怕事情的强大领导者、气候灾难以及种族灭绝、战争和苦难的画面时，我想我们真的能明白为什么大多数人没有走其他路。我们开始明白这种对意义的追求究竟是
coming from. More recently, you have probably encountered a very familiar and now very famous version of Stoicism, which is the Mel Robbins' Let Them Theory. Who hasn't heard about this book? It has had its viral moment. And the thing is, it is basically a modern practical application of some very rudimentary versions of stoic principles. It emphasizes, focuses, focus on what you can control, protecting your peace, not focusing on what you can't control. If you haven't read the Let Them Theory, if you haven't read the book, basically it says, let people be who they are and then move from there. It really highlights the dichotomy of control that Stoicism is very famous for. You have to be able to make that distinction.
从哪里来的。最近，你可能遇到过一个非常熟悉且现在非常著名的斯多葛主义版本，那就是梅尔·罗宾斯的“随他们去理论”（Let Them Theory）。谁没听说过这本书？它已经风靡一时了。问题是，它基本上是一些非常基础的斯多葛原则的现代实际应用。它强调，关注，关注你能控制的事情，保护你的平静，不要关注你无法控制的事情。如果你还没读过“随他们去理论”，如果你还没读过这本书，它基本上说，让人们做他们自己，然后从那里继续前进。它确实突出了斯多葛主义非常著名的控制二分法。你必须能够做出那种区分。
What can I change in a situation? And what am I just going to pain myself and destroy myself trying to change, that being other people's thoughts, other people's actions, other people's personalities, you can't, you can't change that. So focus on what you can. And it is, you know, the Let Them Theory is a direct application in many ways of those Stoic principles about the dichotomy of control. Stoicism also really emphasizes radical acceptance, right? And that's very similar to the Let Them Theory. You know, Mel Robbins really talks about how, radical acceptance is like one of the highest forms of self-love and letting yourself, giving yourself permission to not try and control others and just focus on your own comfort and let, let yourself,
在一种情况下我能改变什么？而我只是在痛苦地折磨自己，试图改变什么，那就是他人的想法、他人的行为、他人的个性，你不能，你不能改变这些。所以专注于你能改变的。而且，你知道，“随他们去理论”在许多方面是那些关于控制二分法的斯多葛原则的直接应用。斯多葛主义也非常强调激进的接受，对吧？这与“随他们去理论”非常相似。你知道，梅尔·罗宾斯确实谈到了激进的接受是如何成为自爱和允许自己、给自己许可不去试图控制他人，只专注于自己的舒适，并让，让自己，
I guess, be uncomfortable in their discomfort is power. That's where you've most likely, most recently encountered stoicism. Ancient stoicism is a little bit more complex than this, though. I think that's a very fun, very rudimentary version of it. It's very powerful. But if you want to go even deeper into stoicism in its ancient form, you have to really understand, again, those core virtues and work on them. And you also have to understand the three pillars of stoicism that I don't think we've even mentioned once yet in this episode. The three pillars of stoicism beyond those four virtues we've spoken about are ethics, logic, logic, and physics. And they're interdependent, so they cannot exist without the other. Sometimes scholars
我想，在他们的不适中感到不适是一种力量。这就是你最近最有可能遇到斯多葛主义的地方。不过，古代斯多葛主义比这要复杂一些。我认为这是一个非常有趣、非常基础的版本。它非常强大。但如果你想更深入地了解古代形式的斯多葛主义，你必须真正理解，再次强调，那些核心美德并致力于它们。你还必须理解斯多葛主义的三大支柱，我想我们在这一集中甚至还没提到过一次。除了我们谈到的那四种美德之外，斯多葛主义的三大支柱是伦理学、逻辑学和物理学。它们是相互依存的，所以没有对方它们就无法存在。有时学者们
arrange these aspects of stoicism in the form of an orchard. So like logic is the enclosing wall, physics is the trees, ethics is the fruit. You need all of them to basically like bear the harvest. So the enclosing kind of wall of the orchard is the first pillar, and that is logic. Using logic, Stoics aim for discipline of perception. They aim to be able to distinguish between true perceptions and false judgments. You can see this is a theme that is coming up a lot. So basically, you cannot have a good life, you cannot be happy if you cannot remove your biases from the objective reality of existence. You need to know the difference between your assumptions and like the objective truth. Otherwise, like, you are always going to fail in logic. You're always going to
将斯多葛主义的这些方面排列成一个果园的形式。比如逻辑学是围墙，物理学是树木，伦理学是果实。你需要所有这些才能基本上收获果实。所以果园的围墙是第一根支柱，那就是逻辑学。利用逻辑，斯多葛派旨在实现感知的纪律。他们旨在能够区分真实的感知和错误的判断。你可以看到这是一个经常出现的主题。所以基本上，如果你不能从存在的客观现实中消除你的偏见，你就不能拥有美好的生活，你就不能快乐。你需要知道你的假设和客观真理之间的区别。否则，就像，你在逻辑上总是会失败。你总是会
struggle with that. So we can apply this by basically having a good sense of reasoning, having a good sense of judgment, really being critical as well of our own biases and being critical of what is true. So let's take the example of, like, you know, somebody has insulted you, somebody has said something that's upset you. Your first reaction is probably going to be anger. And Stoics would say that we all often react too quickly because we're not using sound logic. We're not using an appropriate judgment when approaching a situation. Acting with anger would probably, and will, undermine the possibility of a good outcome, of a rational outcome of a better outcome for yourself. It's going to make it worse. It's maybe going to ruin a relationship.
为此挣扎。所以我们可以通过基本上拥有良好的推理感、良好的判断感，真正批判性地对待我们自己的偏见，并批判性地对待什么是真实的来应用这一点。所以让我们举个例子，比如，你知道，有人侮辱了你，有人说了让你心烦的话。你的第一反应可能是愤怒。而斯多葛派会说，我们所有人往往反应太快，因为我们没有使用合理的逻辑。我们在处理情况时没有使用适当的判断。带着愤怒行事可能会，而且会，破坏获得良好结果、理性结果、对自己更好的结果的可能性。这会让事情变得更糟。它可能会破坏一段关系。
It's maybe going to upset people further. So choosing your first reaction, choosing your first judgment is actually pursuing an irrationally bad outcome because you are not applying logic. Before you react in anger to this perceived insult, a stoic would suggest that you just consider if this person actually meant what they said to be unkind. You consider other aspects or the more objective reality of this situation. do they have a history of saying things like this to you? Is this kind of just a one-off that's really weird? Do they have a motive? Are they a mean person?
它可能会进一步激怒人们。所以选择你的第一反应，选择你的第一判断，实际上是在追求一个非理性的坏结果，因为你没有应用逻辑。在你对这种感知的侮辱做出愤怒反应之前，斯多葛派会建议你考虑一下这个人是否真的想说不友善的话。你考虑其他方面或这种情况更客观的现实。他们以前对你说过这样的话吗？这只是一个非常奇怪的偶然事件吗？他们有动机吗？他们是一个刻薄的人吗？
Have you actually done something that's upset them? Take this extra moment. Hone in on your logic. Explore another explanation. Say as well, they did mean that mean terrible thing that they said to you. Logically, stoicism would say, what would investing in that judgment actually help you? with. Will caring about this make your life better or worse? One of my favorite quotes, again,
你真的做了什么让他们心烦的事吗？多花点时间。磨练你的逻辑。探索另一种解释。再说一遍，他们确实说了那些刻薄、可怕的话。从逻辑上讲，斯多葛主义会说，投资于那种判断实际上能帮你什么？关心这件事会让你的生活变得更好还是更糟？我最喜欢的名言之一，再次，
from Stoicism to Live By, is like, someone despises me, that is their problem. So what? Like, you think being the victim of a mean thought is bad? Imagine being the one to think those mean thoughts every single day. Imagine being in that person's mind. Like, that would be such a sad environment to live in. And it's honestly such a waste. You have only so many minutes alive and you're spending them on somebody else. That's the life that that person is living. They're spending all those minutes that they could have for themselves on you. And honestly, I think that makes you the winner in this situation, to be honest, based on logic. Your only concern should be not doing anything terrible back, not doing anything that is deserving of those
来自《斯多葛主义生活指南》，就像是，有人鄙视我，那是他们的问题。那又怎样？就像，你认为成为刻薄想法的受害者很糟糕吗？想象一下每天都要想那些刻薄想法的人。想象一下在那个人脑子里。那将是一个多么悲伤的生活环境。而且这真的是一种浪费。你活着的分钟数有限，而你却把它们花在别人身上。那是那个人正在过的生活。他们把所有本可以留给自己的时间都花在了你身上。老实说，我认为从逻辑上讲，这让你成为了这种情况下的赢家。你唯一应该关心的是不要做任何可怕的回击，不要做任何值得那些
cruel words and then moving on with your life. Seeing things more clearly, having a better take over your reactions and what is actually happening in the world is a really core part of the Stoic philosophy. And it is the enclosing wall of the orchard because without reasoning, like you cannot engage in these two other pillars, which is physics and ethics. okay, we are going to take a short break here before we get into those pillars because I promise they're not too complicated, they're not too academic or philosophical. But yeah, maybe we can go have a cup of tea. Maybe we can go take a little break from like the philosophy heavy episode. Stick with us. We'll be right back after this short break.
残酷言语的事情，然后继续你的生活。更清晰地看待事物，更好地控制你的反应以及世界上实际发生的事情，是斯多葛哲学的一个非常核心的部分。它是果园的围墙，因为没有推理，你就无法参与另外两个支柱，即物理学和伦理学。好的，在我们进入那些支柱之前，我们要在这里休息一下，因为我保证它们并不太复杂，它们并不太学术或哲学化。但是，是的，也许我们可以去喝杯茶。也许我们可以去从这种哲学沉重的剧集中休息一下。和我们待在一起。我们会在这个简短的休息后回来。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家交流，并深入探讨主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。在I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got? to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代的快克可卡因。明确地说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我愿意在某天谈论快克，但只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌面上还有艾滋病。谢谢你帮我把那句话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade.
是的。我不认为还有比这更重要的年份了，对黑人来说。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了超过十年的
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
我在心理健康领域的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我在说。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person? because you're afraid.
我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得做一个好人很重要，当你活在地球上时。你是一个好人吗？因为你害怕。
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同程度的信任。我希望你真的做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that follow revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesbian, Michael Marantini.
埃伦女士，你伪造了这份特定的检测报告两次，对吧？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭开了一个令人不安的模式。还有两名男子也经历了同样的事情。格雷格·吉莱斯皮，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any matter.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。有两条黄金法则，任何事情
should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
都应该遵循。第一条规则，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条规则，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说要相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《闺蜜》的新一季中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会。
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
我感觉就像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们决定采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我一定要成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的惩罚。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So after logic, we have the second pillar physics. This is not what you think it is. It basically just refers to the study of nature and as things are. Physics is described as like the trees in the orchard
收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。所以逻辑学之后，我们有第二个支柱：物理学。这并不是你所想的那样。它基本上只是指对自然和事物本来面目的研究。物理学被描述为果园里的树木
because it is what everything else basically stems from, right? Stoics really thought that the universe, and still believe that the universe is this rational organism that is governed by divine reason and governed by this maybe higher power of logic. Understanding that the universe is governed by an external force, helps people achieve the discipline and self-control and self-focused that is important to be a stoic, knowing that, again, external events are out of their control, knowing that you are the only thing within your control, you are a very small creature, you're a very small being, you don't have to be worried about everything that's going on. Imagine that you lose your job or like your job hunting at the moment.
因为它是其他一切基本上起源的地方，对吧？斯多葛派确实认为宇宙，并且仍然相信宇宙是一个理性的有机体，受神圣理性支配，受这种可能更高逻辑力量的支配。理解宇宙受外部力量支配，有助于人们实现作为斯多葛派所重要的纪律、自制和自我专注，知道，再次强调，外部事件不在他们的控制范围内，知道你是唯一在自己控制范围内的事物，你是一个非常小的生物，你是一个非常小的存在，你不必担心正在发生的一切。想象一下你失业了，或者像你现在正在找工作。
Like my boyfriend's job hunting, it's terrible. It's really like just such a slog. And this is. It's really stressful and it's really worrying and frustrating for so many reasons. But the pillar of physics basically says, recognize what about this you can change? And then give yourself grace. What can you do now? What can you take responsibility for?
就像我男朋友在找工作，这太糟糕了。这真的就像是一场苦差事。而且这。这真的压力很大，而且因为很多原因让人担心和沮丧。但物理学的支柱基本上说，认识到关于这一点你能改变什么？然后给自己宽容。你现在能做什么？你能为什么负责？
Knowing the way that the universe and the world is, what is in your remit? You know, you can't change global economics. You can't change how competitive things are. But you can change your edge. You can change your approach. And this kind of just helps you again, let go and move on more quickly. Finally, ethics, the final pillar. Ethics is the fruit on the tree in the orchard.
了解宇宙和世界的方式，什么在你的职权范围内？你知道，你无法改变全球经济。你无法改变竞争有多激烈。但你可以改变你的优势。你可以改变你的方法。这基本上再次帮助你放手并更快地前进。最后，伦理学，最后一个支柱。伦理学是果园树上的果实。
And ethics is basically those goals, those moral, virtuous goals that the Stoics have. basically applying logic, applying physics, how are you going to be a good person? How are you going to imbue those four cardinal virtues that we've mentioned before, wisdom, justice, courage, and temperance into your life? You know, there is no point having a grounding philosophy if you cannot practice it. And that is why the fruit is so essential. philosophy is not meant to be something that is just admired. It's meant to be something that's practiced. And the ultimate aim for Stoics and for everybody is to have like a flourishing life. And especially
伦理学基本上是那些目标，那些道德的、美德的目标，斯多葛派所拥有的。基本上应用逻辑，应用物理，你将如何成为一个好人？你将如何把你之前提到的那四种核心美德，即智慧、正义、勇气和节制，融入到你的生活中？你知道，如果你不能实践它，拥有一个基础哲学就没有意义。这就是为什么果实如此重要。哲学不是为了被欣赏，而是为了被实践。斯多葛派和每个人的最终目标是拥有一个繁荣的生活。特别是
for the Stoics, it's to have a flourishing life that is not achieved through wealth or through external success, but through character. So it basically says everything that we've said about how the world works and your control of things in the world, it doesn't matter. how should you act so that you are your happiest and so that you are a good person and so that you have accepted the things that you can't change and basically you are focused on the things that you can. This is why I think a stoic mindset is the best mindset you can have in your 20s, which I've already said, but I need to really nail down this point. So much of our 20s is just trying to force things to happen in one specific way according to what we think would make us the happiest.
对于斯多葛派来说，它是要拥有一个不是通过财富或外部成功，而是通过品格来实现的繁荣生活。所以它基本上说，我们所说的关于世界如何运作以及你对世界事物的控制的一切，都不重要。你应该如何行动，以便你最快乐，以便你是一个好人，以便你接受了你无法改变的事情，并且基本上你专注于你能改变的事情。这就是为什么我认为斯多葛心态是你二十岁时能拥有的最好心态，我已经说过了，但我需要真正强调这一点。我们二十岁的大部分时间只是试图强迫事情按照我们认为会让我们最快乐的特定方式发生。
I'm going to meet the love of my life at this age. Then we're going to move cities at this time. And then by 27, 28, I'll have my dream job, my dream life. And it's all going to work out exactly as I want. But it's not always up to you. Honestly, most of it is just luck. And that really sucks. But the people who I found enjoy their 20s the most just lean so deeply into the flow of the universe that they don't, they almost don't care where they end up because they know that if they're kind and they know that if they work hard, they're going to end up somewhere amazing. And I think that is just in many ways in my many short years, like the secret to happiness. It's this strange philosophy of not holding on too tight because if it is meant to be,
我会在这个年纪遇到我一生的挚爱。然后我们会在这个时候搬到不同的城市。然后到27、28岁，我会有我梦想的工作，我梦想的生活。一切都会完全按照我想要的进行。但并不总是取决于你。老实说，大部分只是运气。这真的很糟糕。但我发现最享受二十岁的人，只是深深地融入了宇宙的流动中，以至于他们几乎不在乎最终会去哪里，因为他们知道如果他们善良，他们知道如果他们努力工作，他们最终会去某个了不起的地方。我认为这在很多方面，在我短暂的几年里，就是幸福的秘诀。这是一种奇怪的哲学，不要抓得太紧，因为如果是命中注定的，
it will stay and if it's not meant to be, you'll just hurt yourself more, trying to force things to be the way that you want them to be. When also, you don't always know what's going to be the best outcome. Like, you actually don't know what's going to make you happiest. You just have to be prepared for any outcome and make do with what that is and know that you can make happiness within that. Okay, so this brings us to the huge major question of the episode. What impact stoicism actually have for our brain and on our psychology. This may all sound really nice in theory. Does it actually help? It's basically what we want to talk about. And the short answer is 1,000 percent, yes, it does. In fact, new research shows that authentic stoicism, so not like the
它会留下来，如果不是命中注定的，你只会因为试图强迫事情按照你想要的方式发展而伤害自己更多。而且，你并不总是知道什么是最好的结果。就像，你实际上不知道什么会让你最快乐。你只需要为任何结果做好准备，并利用它做出改变，并知道你可以在其中创造幸福。好的，这把我们带到了这一集巨大的主要问题。斯多葛主义对我们的大脑和心理究竟有什么影响？这在理论上听起来可能很好。它真的有帮助吗？这基本上是我们想谈论的。简短的回答是1000%的，是的，确实有。事实上，新的研究表明，真实的斯多葛主义，所以不是那种
suppress your emotions type, predicts much better well-being, a much greater sense of happiness, better friendships. And we know this from one of the biggest bodies of work done on stoicism research called the Stoics Attitude and Behaviors Scale. So there's this very famous philosopher and psychotherapist. His name is Tim Labon. And he was, was, is the lead researcher in creating this scale. And this scale basically identifies seven dimensions of stoicism and how they relate to happiness. So it gets people self-reported, asked people a bunch of questions that are kind of like thinly veiled at targeting these things like virtue, things like mindfulness, benevolence, and then it looks at how their life is turning out. Are they a happy person? This scale has been tested on thousands of people
压抑你情绪的类型，预示着更好的幸福感、更强烈的幸福感、更好的友谊。我们从关于斯多葛主义研究的最大机构之一，即“斯多葛态度和行为量表”中知道这一点。所以有一位非常著名的哲学家和心理治疗师。他的名字叫蒂姆·拉邦。他是创建该量表的首席研究员。该量表基本上确定了斯多葛主义的七个维度以及它们如何与幸福相关。所以它让人们进行自我报告，问人们一堆问题，这些问题有点像隐晦地针对这些事情，比如美德、正义、正念、仁慈，然后它观察他们的生活结果如何。他们是一个快乐的人吗？该量表已经在成千上万的人身上进行了测试
worldwide. And not just people who say they practice stoicism, but just the average person, some of whom end up adopting stoic principles kind of by accident. And the results are so clear, people who score highly on a stoic lifestyle. Everything, like not everything, but a lot of stuff is better for them. Less anxiety, less anger, greater resilience. In contrast, people who suppress their emotions, people who don't have a guiding philosophy like stoicism, have low acceptance, more anxiety, and they don't have a core value set. So they do worse on a lot of these other scales. Neurologically as well, stoicism makes us happier, it makes us more patient, kind, better able to respond rather than react, because it allows us to interrupt the fearful
全世界。不仅仅是那些说他们实践斯多葛主义的人，还有普通人，其中一些人最终偶然采用了斯多葛原则。结果非常清晰，在斯多葛式生活方式上得分高的人。一切，就像不是一切，但很多事情对他们来说更好。更少的焦虑，更少的愤怒，更强的复原力。相比之下，压抑情绪的人，没有像斯多葛主义这样指导哲学的人，接受度低，焦虑更多，而且他们没有核心价值观集。所以他们在许多其他量表上表现更差。在神经学上，斯多葛主义也让我们更快乐，它让我们更有耐心、更善良，更能做出反应而不是做出反应，因为它允许我们打断恐惧的
parts of our brain and redirect our behavior in that split, like 40 to 50 milliseconds, where we get a say over what we're going to do. It allows us to be present in that moment, in that choice. When you have a guiding philosophy like stoicism, it basically puts your frontal cortex more in charge, that rational part of your brain, more in charge of the fast, immediate, often irrational parts of your brain that just want you to choose and just want you to urgently do something and then often lead you down that irrational path of reacting. I think the greatest evidence of stoicism's psychological power is how
我们大脑的某些部分，并在那短短的40到50毫秒内重定向我们的行为，让我们对即将要做的事情拥有发言权。它让我们能够活在当下，专注于那个选择。当你拥有像斯多葛主义这样的指导哲学时，它基本上会让你的前额叶皮层——也就是你大脑中理性的部分——更多地去掌控那些快速、直接、往往是非理性的部分，因为那些部分只是想让你立刻做出选择，急于做点什么，而这往往会把你引向那种非理性的反应路径。我认为斯多葛主义心理力量的最有力证据在于它
prominently it appears in palliative and chronic pain research. You know, people who are at the end of their life. People who are really sick, people who are experiencing pain on all or most days, there is increasing evidence to suggest that our beliefs about pain can actually influence our experience of pain. Now, that's not to say a positive mindset fixes anything or everything, absolutely not. No, no, no. It's basically just that in these intense situations where sometimes there is nothing that you can do, the only thing you do have control over is your mindset. And people who act on that mindset feel more empowered because it's about focusing on the thing that is for them and that they can, again, control.
在姑息治疗和慢性疼痛研究中表现得多么突出。你知道，那些处于生命尽头的人，那些病得很重的人，那些每天或大部分时间都在经历疼痛的人，越来越多的证据表明，我们对疼痛的信念实际上可以影响我们对疼痛的体验。这并不是说积极的心态能解决一切问题，绝对不是。不，不，不。这基本上只是说，在这些无法改变的极端情况下，你唯一能控制的就是你的心态。而那些基于这种心态采取行动的人会感到更有力量，因为这关乎专注于那些属于他们且他们能够再次掌控的事情。
One study in Victoria, in Australia, where I'm from, looked at 338 chronic pain patients from 20 to 100. and again, they measured people based on this stoic fortitude, stoic attitude quality, their ability to not endure, but their ability to accept what they were going through. And what they found was that people who measured high in these traits, they reported less depression, less anxiety, less pain severity as well. Let me give you one more piece of evidence for this, because this was also observed back in the 90s, where, again,
澳大利亚维多利亚州的一项研究调查了338名20到100岁的慢性疼痛患者。他们再次根据这种斯多葛式的坚韧、斯多葛式的态度品质来衡量人们，即他们忍受的不是痛苦本身，而是他们接受所经历之事的能力。研究发现，在这些特质上得分较高的人，报告的抑郁、焦虑和疼痛程度都较低。让我再给你们提供一个证据，因为这在90年代也曾被观察到，当时，同样地，
there was this positive association between having a stoic attitude and the quality of life for people with muscular dystrophy. The study found that when you were able to adopt this guiding philosophy, when you were able to be like, this just really sucks, these are my cards, what am I going to do with them? What cards do I have in my favor? What do I not? What am I going to do with the ones that I do? These people are happier. we will definitely get to some of the criticisms of this mindset. But when you think about it, like, stoicism is powerful because it is so therapeutic and because it really teaches acceptance. And that is why it actually does show up in so many therapeutic practices.
人们发现斯多葛式的态度与肌营养不良症患者的生活质量之间存在正相关。研究发现，当你能够采纳这种指导哲学，当你能够说：“这真的很糟糕，这就是我手中的牌，我该怎么打？我有哪些有利的牌？哪些没有？我该怎么处理我手中的牌？”时，这些人会更快乐。我们肯定会谈到这种心态的一些批评意见。但当你思考时，斯多葛主义之所以强大，是因为它具有治疗作用，而且它确实教会了人们接受。这就是为什么它实际上出现在如此多的治疗实践中。
Cognitive behavioral therapy, for example, is a stoic therapy. It basically says, like, how you think about things influences how you behave to, towards them, which influences your life. And if you can change how you think about them, you change your perception, you can change everything else. Same with like dialectical behavior therapy that basically really emphasizes radical acceptance. Changing what you can change. Again, this like underlying philosophy and pillar that comes through this all. It's also woven into things like rational emotive behavioral therapy, which focuses on changing self-defeating attitudes in people. It's also involved in mindfulness. It's involved in family therapy systems as well.
例如，认知行为疗法就是一种斯多葛式的疗法。它基本上说，你对事物的看法会影响你对它们的行为，进而影响你的生活。如果你能改变对它们的看法，改变你的认知，你就能改变其他一切。辩证行为疗法也是如此，它非常强调彻底的接受。改变你能改变的。同样，这种潜在的哲学和支柱贯穿于这一切。它也融入了理性情绪行为疗法等事物中，该疗法专注于改变人们的自我挫败态度。它也涉及正念，也涉及家庭治疗系统。
The more you start looking for stoicism, the more you start like searching for it, the more it ends up showing up in all these places and that have evidence for helping people get better and for helping people be happier. And I feel like now that you've listened to this episode, you will start seeing it everywhere as well. It's just such a powerful way to live your life, yes, philosophically, but also psychologically. Okay, before we go any further, we do have to talk about the criticisms. I feel like I really wanted to butt in with a lot of them there, but I knew we were going to get to it. We have to talk about the downsides here because no life philosophy is immune to some problems or some hiccups. This one included, the big part of it being the toxic.
你越开始寻找斯多葛主义，你越开始搜索它，它就越会在所有这些地方出现，而这些地方都有证据表明它能帮助人们变得更好，帮助人们变得更快乐。我觉得既然你已经听完了这一集，你也会开始在各处看到它。这确实是一种强大的生活方式，是的，从哲学上讲是这样，从心理学上讲也是如此。好了，在我们继续之前，我们必须谈谈批评意见。我觉得我真的很想插嘴说很多，但我知道我们迟早会谈到这一点。我们必须谈谈这里的缺点，因为没有任何生活哲学能免于一些问题或小插曲。包括这一种，其中很大一部分就是有毒的
positivity, the idea that how you think about things will just change everything about the world. And we know that's not true. There's this whole thing in stoicism of like, the world has to be dealt with as it is. And you should not spend time imagining an ideal society and you should just focus on what you can do. And you should be focused on your own virtues and focused on your own logic and ethics and blah, blah, blah, blah. There are definitely some people who would look at that and would interpret this as like, head down, don't get angry, don't react. If you're a good person, you don't have anything to worry about. That's all you needed to do.
积极性，即认为你对事物的看法会改变世界上的一切。我们知道那不是真的。斯多葛主义中有一种观点，即世界必须按其本来面目来对待。你不应该花时间去想象一个理想的社会，而应该只专注于你能做的事情。你应该专注于你自己的美德，专注于你自己的逻辑和道德，等等等等。肯定有一些人会看到这一点，并将其解读为：低头做事，不要生气，不要反应。如果你是一个好人，你就没什么可担心的。这就是你需要做的全部。
You don't need to improve anything beyond that. The world is, as it is, you have done your part. When we think about the world as it is right now, it's just not a mindset that most of us can have. It's a very problematic mindset. If we take stoicism to be that version, you know, to take. a really contemporary example, like there are people protesting against dictatorships, against injustice all over the world at the moment. And they're very rightfully angry. And they may not
你不需要在此之外改进任何东西。世界就是这样，你已经尽了你的本分。当我们思考现在的世界时，这并不是我们大多数人能拥有的心态。这是一种非常有问题的思维方式。如果我们把斯多葛主义理解为那个版本，你知道，举一个非常当代的例子，比如现在世界各地都有人抗议独裁、抗议不公。他们理所当然地感到愤怒。他们可能
be living in that moment according to the specific bylines of stoicism, but does that mean that they're doing life incorrectly? Does that mean that they're sabotaging their chances at happiness if they just focus more on what they could control? No. Like it needs to be done. And it's at moments like this, that stoicism does face accusations of being a very privileged life philosophy to follow. This notion of protecting your peace and suggesting that people's pain, for example, people's worrying and suffering could be improved with the mindset shift. That can be seen as very patronizing and probably very wrong. I think at worst, stoicism has been accused of being a lifestyle accessory to the wealthy.
并没有按照斯多葛主义的具体准则生活在那个时刻，但这是否意味着他们的人生过错了？这是否意味着如果他们只关注自己能控制的事情，就是在破坏自己获得幸福的机会？不。这需要被完成。正是在这样的时刻，斯多葛主义面临着被指责为一种非常特权的追随生活哲学。这种保护你内心平静的观念，以及暗示人们的痛苦，例如人们的担忧和苦难，可以通过心态转变来改善的建议，可能被视为非常傲慢，而且很可能是错误的。我认为最坏的情况是，斯多葛主义被指责为富人的生活方式配件。
and maybe a way to kind of silence some things that we should be loud about. And at its best, I think, hopefully we can understand and see stilicism as a philosophy that says, yes, the world cannot be good unless you make yourself good within it, but also you do have a duty, you do have that ethical duty to go out and do something about injustice and do something about what you're seeing around you. So when you really understand that, I think you can hopefully see that it doesn't ask you to be passive and still. It asks you to really kind of get your hands dirty at times if that is what's going to make the world better and that should be your priority. Okay, so let's leave that behind. Let's talk about how we can actually apply stoicism if that
也许是一种掩盖我们应该大声疾呼的事情的方式。而在最好的情况下，我认为，希望我们能理解并看到斯多葛主义是一种哲学，它说：是的，除非你让自己变得优秀，否则世界不可能变好，但你也有责任，你有道德义务去走出去，为不公正做点什么，为你周围所见的事情做点什么。所以当你真正理解这一点时，我希望你能明白，它并不要求你被动和静止。它要求你在必要时真正地去“弄脏双手”，如果那是让世界变得更好的方式，那应该是你的优先事项。好了，让我们把这些抛在脑后。让我们谈谈如果我们想应用斯多葛主义，该如何去做，
is something you want to do and if you want some of those psychological benefits we spoke about. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
如果你想获得我们所说的那些心理益处的话。2%。这是在有自动扶梯的情况下选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行交流，透过主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即T-W-O-Percent，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of course. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克毒品。明确地说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为当然，快克。我愿意在某天谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在桌上还有艾滋病。谢谢你完成那句话。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多不可思议的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要，还是因为你害怕才做一个好人？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search Learn the Hard Way and listen now.
那是两种不同程度的信任。我希望你真正地成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序，搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这是一场长达数年的法庭斗争，旨在证明真相。你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格，莱斯皮安，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。第一条，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。
I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们采取了行动。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. One of the selling points of stoicism is ironically how cheap it is and how little it needs from you.
我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。斯多葛主义的卖点之一，讽刺的是，它有多便宜，以及它对你的要求有多低。
How do you practice everyday stoicism? Here are some examples. Firstly, you need to recognize that much of the well-being talk pushed on us today suggests that you should remain positive all the time without exception. All you should be working towards is to just be happy and to not have any negative. emotions. This is very different to Stoicism. A practice that was very popular amongst the Stoics was something called negative visualization. Basically, imagine, and this is going to sound so counter to what maybe a therapist would suggest you or somebody else, but imagine at the
你如何实践日常的斯多葛主义？这里有一些例子。首先，你需要认识到，今天推崇给我们的许多关于幸福的谈话都暗示你应该始终保持积极，没有例外。你所追求的全部应该是快乐，没有任何负面情绪。这与斯多葛主义非常不同。斯多葛学派中非常流行的一种练习叫做“负面可视化”。基本上，想象一下——这听起来可能与治疗师或其他人建议你的完全相反——但想象一下在
Saturday of your day everything that could go wrong that day. And also then imagine all the ways that you could fix all those things that would go wrong. And then move through the day knowing that you have the tools to confront these problems. Essentially, think about the worst possible what if, and then visualize yourself still dealing with that. This is very different from being anxious all day. This is called negative visualization. It requires understanding that even if things do go wrong, it's not the end of the world.
你一天的开始，想象这一天可能出错的所有事情。然后想象你可以修复所有这些出错事情的方法。然后带着你知道自己有能力面对这些问题的认知度过这一天。本质上，思考最坏的“如果……会怎样”，然后想象自己仍然在处理它。这与整天焦虑完全不同。这被称为负面可视化。它需要理解，即使事情真的出错了，也不是世界末日。
You are able to confront issues as they arise. you are able to, no matter what it is, you will be okay, push through it. That's a very helpful practice. You could literally try tomorrow. Tomorrow, what's the worst thing that could happen in your life? Imagine it. Imagine yourself dealing with it. You're good to go. You have that armor on. I honestly think about this a lot and I think about like if it doesn't work, what's going to happen? I feel like at the moment I've been facing a lot of, like, fear of embarrassment, fear of cringe from doing parts of my job I probably should do more, posting online, that kind of stuff. And really having that mentality of like truly what's the worst, what if that could happen,
你有能力在问题出现时面对它们。你有能力，无论发生什么，你都会没事的，坚持下去。这是一个非常有用的练习。你明天就可以尝试。明天，你生活中可能发生的最糟糕的事情是什么？想象一下。想象自己处理它。你准备好了。你穿上了那层盔甲。我真的经常思考这个问题，我想如果它不起作用，会发生什么？我觉得目前我面临很多，比如，对尴尬的恐惧，对做我可能应该做的工作部分感到畏缩的恐惧，在网上发帖之类的。真正拥有那种“最坏的情况到底会怎样”的心态，
is life changing because you just put everything into perspective. What's the worst thing that could happen? Somebody could judge me. Somebody could be mad at me. That's easy. Let's move on. Let's move forward. Another very simple stoicism practice is obviously gratitude and also generosity,
是改变生活的，因为你把一切都放在了视角中。最坏的情况会发生什么？有人可能会评判我。有人可能会对我生气。这很容易。让我们继续。让我们前进。另一个非常简单的斯多葛主义练习显然是感恩和慷慨，
taking what you have extra of, feeling grateful for it, passing it forward. One practice I saw somebody talk about similar to this is basically making a list of all the things you truly do not need in your life and then also a list of the things you do need. And then sitting with that list of all the things that you have that you don't need and feeling grateful for that, grateful for this like abundance and also more confident that there is a lot you could go without that you still have. So you don't need to worry too much about achievement. You don't need to worry too much. You'll get attached too much to money or possessions because if all of that faded, you'd still be okay. Even just simply asking yourself better questions
利用你多余的东西，对它心存感激，并传递下去。我看到有人谈论的一个类似的练习是，基本上列出你生活中真正不需要的所有东西，然后列出你确实需要的东西。然后看着那张你拥有但不需要的东西的清单，对它心存感激，对这种丰盛心存感激，同时也更自信地认为，即使没有很多东西，你依然可以过得很好。所以你不需要太担心成就。你不需要太担心。你不会太依恋金钱或财产，因为如果这一切都消失了，你仍然会没事的。甚至只是简单地问自己更好的问题
about your life decisions is stoicism. Asking yourself like, why do I want this? Is it because of external rewards? Is it because of my own desire? That is stoicism. asking yourself, like, who am I trying to impress? What do I think I'm controlling by trying to control these things in my life? That is stoicism. Identifying why, or the areas where you are overworking, people pleasing, overthinking, and whether that is the best logical use of your time is stoicism. A stoic practice is like basically anything that lets you be more present, that lets you see the world more clearly for what it is without self-deception, without false ideas of control, and to just see your anxieties, see your worries,
关于你的人生决定也是斯多葛主义。问自己，比如，我为什么想要这个？是因为外部奖励吗？是因为我自己的欲望吗？这就是斯多葛主义。问自己，比如，我试图给谁留下深刻印象？通过试图控制生活中的这些事情，我认为我在控制什么？这就是斯多葛主义。识别你过度工作、讨好他人、过度思考的原因，以及这是否是你时间的最优逻辑使用，这就是斯多葛主义。斯多葛式的练习就像基本上任何让你更活在当下的事情，让你更清晰地看待世界本来面目的事情，没有自欺欺人，没有错误的控制观念，只是看到你的焦虑，看到你的担忧，
see everything that could go wrong and just get on with living and get on with being kind and get on with experiencing because, oh my God, it's going to sound so cliche, like tomorrow isn't promised. You just have to be as present as possible. So I think that's all I have time for. Thank you for listening if you have made it as far. this was definitely a very philosophy-heavy episode. I like to do one of those every once in a while.
看到所有可能出错的事情，然后继续生活，继续善良，继续体验，因为，天哪，这听起来太陈词滥调了，明天是不确定的。你只需要尽可能活在当下。所以我认为我只有这么多时间了。如果你已经听到了这里，谢谢你的收听。这绝对是一集非常哲学沉重的节目。我偶尔喜欢做一集这样的。
But one that I still hope was enlightening to you. I know you're here for psychology. I feel like sometimes these go hand in hand. I hope you feel inspired to take control of what you can. I hope you feel inspired to see life more clearly. It's definitely something I'm trying to do. And I hope you feel inspired to be a good, fair, courageous person. that is something I feel very strongly about right now. I feel like it's one of the only things
但我仍然希望这一集对你有启发。我知道你是为了心理学而来。我觉得有时这些是相辅相成的。我希望你感到有动力去控制你能控制的事情。我希望你感到有动力更清晰地看待生活。这绝对是我正在努力做的事情。我希望你感到有动力成为一个善良、公平、勇敢的人。这是我目前感受非常强烈的事情。我觉得这是唯一的事情之一
we can control in such what is seemingly looks like a terrible world. So if that is the only thing you get out of this episode that you are good and you can prove that the world is good by being good, that will be enough for me. So I appreciate you listening. Thank you as always to our research team, including Lucy Davidson, for her assistance with this episode today. make sure that you are following us on Instagram. If you have not yet watched an episode on Netflix, if you are in the US or Canada, go and do that right now.
在这样一个看似糟糕的世界里，我们能控制的事情。所以如果这是你从这一集中得到的唯一收获，即你是善良的，并且你可以通过做一个好人来证明世界是美好的，那对我来说就足够了。所以我感谢你的收听。一如既往地感谢我们的研究团队，包括露西·戴维森，感谢她今天对本集节目的协助。确保你在Instagram上关注我们。如果你还没有在Netflix上观看过一集，如果你在美国或加拿大，现在就去看看吧。
We'd love to see you over there. As always, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
我们很乐意在那里见到你。一如既往，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔。我们很快就会再谈。2%。这是在有自动扶梯的情况下选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。我在我的播客《2%》中。
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即TWA%，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be. his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们采取了行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app,
从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。那是一个疯狂的年份。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的一年。在iHeartRadio应用程序收听《Look Back at it》，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe. to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
Apple Podcasts，或任何你获取播客的地方。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人，基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这在任何地方都不安全，但你正在与一位知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要使用它，
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，欧文斯女士，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男子。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个iHeart播客。保证是人类制作的。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。